the dumbest man in America is back Don
Lemon diving head first into a hornet's
nest of controversy while offering up
his hot take on age in politics comes as
Dems privately freak out on whether Joe
Biden is too old to run for re-election
fearing a kamla nomination would be
worse presidential candidate Nikki Haley
pushing this idea
in the America
permanent politician will finally retire
we'll have term limits for congress in
mandatory mental competency tests for
politicians over 75 years old
Don stepping on a landmod while
responding to that
this whole talk about age makes me
uncomfortable I think that I think it's
the wrong road to go down she says
people you know politicians or something
are not in their Prime Nikki Haley isn't
in their Prime sorry when a woman is
considered being a prime in her 20s and
30s and maybe 40s that's not according
to me Prime for what it depends I mean
it's just like Prime if you look it up
it'll if you look if you Google women's
a woman in a prime it'll say 20s 30s and
40s
thank you Dawn for saying what everybody
truly believes
you later said he regrets his comment
calling it in Artful all right Dana I
have been suffering from CNN uh anorexia
ever since they got rid of stelter and
Cuomo I have nothing on my show I have
segments that are just empty and thank
you
thank you Don Lemon do you think he did
this deliberately because his shows are
tanking he's all of his no one watches
it maybe people are going to watch him
now because he says more idiotics there
was a suggestion I saw a headline
somewhere that said yes that it's so bad
over there in the morning that it has
become must watch TV because you can't
believe what you're actually seeing it's
that bad like a train wreck I was we
were just getting ready to do Newsroom
this morning and I'm looking at my phone
of course and I see Janice Dean put that
on Instagram and I said surely not what
you know and then I said a word that I'd
like it in trouble for probably more
than he'll get in trouble for saying
this
um and the visceral reaction was
interesting for me so I am I'll be the
same age as Nikki Haley in a couple
months and my my initial rest was like
just rage and I said a word oh did you
that was like even stronger than
anything what did it rhyme with
Buck oh wow I was mad and also I was
like it's one thing to say uh that I
think that that was an in our it wasn't
just in Artful it was a ridiculous
comment but it was interesting the rage
and I did wonder well any of the women's
groups stand up and say anything yes
well Hillary Clinton come out and say oy
how dare you women can are in their
leadership Prime and in their power
Prime uh and no none of them did it the
view didn't say anything nothing
artificial stance okay
Don Lemon is a brave man and I'll tell
you why every now and then Jesse you
know this you're sitting before the
screen you go you have something comes
into your head and you go should I jump
off this Cliff or not he was comparing
he was comparing reproduction to
cognitive function you would pass your
Prime they're talking about cognitive
function and he goes past your Prime and
his brain's working and he goes
reproduction I know they're different
but this could be great you've been
there he was trying to to do you Jesse
and he failed but he'd even never try to
do Jesse yes only you could do just only
I can do Jesse and Jesse would say if I
was doing Jesse he would say women are
in their Prime in their late teens
that's awesome that's Jesse doing Jesse
that says he's doing Jesse doing Jesse
doing Jesse see what I just did there
most people when they do these shows and
I speak for myself clearly prepare yeah
he knows what he's going to say going
into the segment right so he had
prepared something to say and this is
what Don had prepared to say right he
had actually maybe did he not research
it maybe because
he told people to Google or if you do
Google it it doesn't say that it's much
later so I I you know I want to give him
the benefit of the doubt why yeah why he
wouldn't do that to anybody screw him
yeah exactly the thing is so I always
accept an apology Jessica you know and
also because I want him to stick around
because it helps my show but did he
actually apologize he said it was in
there he regretted it yeah that's not an
apology is it well I don't know
okay it counts his PR person wrote it
exactly again but it doesn't count with
people right so he ticked with people
I guess with the boss there right it
said you have to say something so he
said I'm going to say the least personal
thing that I can say which is so
divorced from reality he stared a woman
in her late 20s and a woman in her 30s
in the eye and Caitlin Collins and Poppy
Harlow I think those are the very or
Caitlyn Collins might be 30. so I think
she's with them whatever it is whatever
I don't know and you don't see well or
race no no one said anything about race
just see gender okay you're saying it's
because he's black geez Jessica oh man
he's here to high achieving women
that he shares this job with that he was
demoted for right and is hanging on by a
thread
and decided to insult women and women
that they inevitably admire right if
they don't like Nikki Haley they sure
like a lot of politicians have been in
their 50s 60s 70s and been successful
like the Hillary Clinton's of the world
insulting Ruth Bader Ginsburg all of it
and
it made me think back to when he said to
Essie cupp when she confused two numbers
she was on a show and he sold the 10
o'clock hour and he goes oh is that
mommy brain right like that she short
circuits now because she's given birth
when I do that
it's horrible it's an insult to moms
exactly yeah judge okay so what he said
in addition to saying that that Haley
isn't in her prime he said be careful
about turning off older voters I mean
the guy isn't even listening to himself
as he trashes women who are over 40. he
says be careful about trashing the older
voters first of all he did Google it he
said he Googled it 20 30 and 40. and
then he takes it back seven hours later
he says I regret it age doesn't Define
you professionally or personally but the
truth is I mean that this guy would
actually go out there and trash women
and say you're only in your Prime how
dumb do you have to be to say something
like that I mean think about who's
looks like that anymore and Kamala
Harris I'm sure if she heard about it
she would have said something about it
she should have just done it anyway
you know what that would have been great
if she had done something but the thing
is he made so he made this choice of
comparing reproduction to cognitive
function yeah that was that was so it's
like it is like technically he was right
in his Twisted Brain that it's like oh
once you're past childbirth you're past
your pride that's the way he was
thinking he didn't connect the two no he
absolutely didn't connect them so
entertaining so thank you Don I'm going
to do this again tomorrow on my show
just for you I've never watching fox and
friends again
I wouldn't see it at every morning I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now